>> So Sebastian, this sounds really useful but really difficult.
Are you telling me I have to write a bunch of new features?
>> The cool thing about support vector machines is that you don't.
There's something called the kernel trick.
>> So are you going to explain the kernel trick to us?
I bet you are. >> No won't really, I'll just give you the gist of it.
There are functions that take a low dimensional input space or
feature space, and map it to a very high dimensional space.
So that what's used to be not linear separable and
turn this into a separable problem.
And without going into any detail, these functions are called kernels.
And I encourage you to check out in this, these aren't just functions with
a feature space, these are functions over two inputs.
And when you apply the kernel trick to change your input space from x,y
to a much larger input space, separate the data point using support
vector machines, and then take the solution and go back to the original space.
You now have a non linear separation.
And this is the really cool thing about support vector machines.
You can take a very simple idea of finding the best linear separator, or
linear line between different classes, apply what's called the kernel trick
in a higher dimensional space, and what you effectively get is a very, very powerful
system to set datasets apart where the division line might be nonlinear.
That is really cool,
and one of the most central tricks in all of machine learning